c'est un beau symbole olivier finances
et trois présidents c'est important
qu'il soit là aujourd'hui on rappelle en
la grande absence de donald trump
oui en tout cas c'est le retour du de ce
qu'on a appelé le commandent decency
c'est à dire la manière de gérer de
manière convenable la politique
américaine et la présence des présidents
des anciens présidents américains à part
jimmy carter qui est très malade et
sinon il serait également venu démontre
qu effectivement il y à une sorte vous
savez d'unité ou du lion au delà des des
prises de position partisanes entre
démocrates et républicains en tout cas
les républicains classiques comme george
bush les représente très bien et puis de
l'autre côté il ya cette autre amérique
qui représente effectivement par donald
trump et par une grande partie encore
des prêts de 75 millions de gens qui ont
voté pour lui et qui ont il faut pas
l'oublier pendant quatre ans vomi refusé
cette cette représentation cette image
que l'on voit est toute la difficulté de
joe biden ça va être de réconcilier ces
deux amériques celles qui trouvent que
cette image actuellement et l'image de
la réconciliation
personnifiez et ceux qui vomissent cette
image au titre de l'arrêt de washington
et de la corruption qu'il est censé
représenter
est ce que ce que ce qu'on vient de dire
est très juste dire que joe biden était
lui a été élu pour la première fois en
1972 c'est un politicien madré c'est un
parlementaire madray c'est quelqu'un qui
saura trouver les mots du consensus pour
tenter d'apaiser va-t-il réussir c'est
tout
toute la question qu'on va se poser mais
en tout cas il a les attributs
il a l'âge il a le comportement pour
pouvoir réussir effectivement